hi everyone I'm Elin Dew a PhD student
at the MIT computer science and AI
laboratory or csail and I'm researching
on how to construct intelligent robot
agents today I'll be explaining how AI
image generators work
first question
how do large text-guided diffusion
models work
so large text guided diffusion models
are trained on a very large data set of
images and captions on the internet when
you search up different words on Google
search you can find all types of
different images for a particular phrase
text image diffusion models are trained
on millions and millions of these image
and text pairs on the internet and
they're trained to be able to
reconstruct and generate images are
similar to the images on the internet
because they're trained on such massive
amounts of data you can imagine that
when you get when you give this model a
new text prompt because it's been
trained to be able to recapture the
images that it's seen before it is able
to generate an image that matches the
prompt next question
what makes the fusion model so impactful
so I think the main reason why we're
seeing all these incredible advances
with these diffusion models is because
of the fact that we are training them
with so much data and with so much
computational power so the idea of
diffusion models themselves uh it's a
very old idea but what really makes them
at work now is the idea that we've now
we now have so many so much
computational resources and so much
computational power they were able to
train them at very large skills
can you sell AI image generated images
yeah I guess
that isn't really a copyright or
anything like that and I think people
have uh definitely be selling some of
these AI artworks like I heard that
mid-journey diffusion uh was selling
artwork for millions of dollars each
month so yeah yeah I think you can
definitely sell them I I think that this
is a question of like maybe we should
add some licensing or something like
that because these models are trained on
many many images that are copyrighted
but right now it seems like you can't
easily sell them
how are models prevented from showing
harmful or offensive images especially
concerning the use of Open Source
programs yeah this is a great question
in practice these models are trained on
hundreds of millions of images on the
internet so there's all types of harmful
themes on the internet in practice one
way to prevent these models from doing
this would be to very carefully select
and curate the images that these models
are trained on but currently this is a
huge problem with a lot of these models
which is why I think that a lot of these
companies are not willing to release
they're very large pre-trained models
for public use right now
are there potential applications of
generative AI outside of image or text
can you apply it for example to robotics
or control yeah I think this is a really
great question uh actually we I've been
working on some work where we have been
directly applying these generative
models exactly for the Showcase of
control we have this paper called
planning was diffusion where you can use
this similar process the similar
generative process to represent
different trajectories of actions so you
can train these models on huge amounts
of robotic actions or manipulation
demonstrations in video and you can
imagine you can give the robot a new
instruction like pick up this mug and
then it can it can use the large model
generative model that's trained on
millions of other videos of robots
picking up objects so I think there's
many different applications for these
generated models for example in robotics
or you can imagine for other domains
such as protein synthesis or molecular
design
well it looks like we're out of
questions now thank you for listening
and asking all these wonderful questions
hopefully you learned something about AI
image generation thank you
[Music]